the russian invasion of ukraine
happening thousands of miles away is
about to have a big impact here at home
after slapping sanctions on russia
president biden in the white house
warning americans to be prepared for
economic strain
defending freedom will have cost
for us as well and here at home
we need to be honest about that should
people across the country expect to see
that kind of a number when they go to
gas up their car five dollars six
dollars well again i think as you heard
the president say last week
standing up for our values is not
without cost
what we're trying to do is minimize that
cost so i don't have a prediction of it
right now because we're trying to
minimize the impact on the global energy
markets response to our sanctions will
be painful for america and the
department of homeland security is
telling american companies to be ready
for possible russian cyber attacks while
putin already unleashing a cyber assault
on ukraine today and russian tanks and
troops are quote unquoiled from their
holding positions and are ready to go
before we get our reaction let's go to
bill hemmer of course we've got bill
hammer at the billboard
how are you it's good to see you you've
been working all day
yeah nice to see you dana what's the
update uh here is the situation it's
midnight in kiev and it's one o'clock in
the morning in moscow and we're waiting
on word as to whether or not putin's
going to pull the trigger there was a
headline about an hour ago about um
forces down here in southeastern ukraine
requesting military assistance on behalf
of moscow to help with ukrainian
aggression that was the word from the
kremlin now okay here's the neighborhood
poland to the west belarus to the north
russia to the east and ukraine is the
focus right now i'm going to show you a
couple slides dana so our viewers at
home get a sense of this this is what we
believe based on three days ago right
this is the 20th of february every white
circle you see here
is an existing military position and
every red circle you see is a new
military presence okay that's as of
three days ago let me just go forward a
couple screens here and
um this is where we believe the russian
military was in the fall
existing military positions down here in
crimea southeastern ukraine all right
that was prior to the current buildup
this is as of the end of december
december 29th you see the red circle
start to pop up in russia here down in
crimea i'll take you to the end of
january now january 25th see this
activity here that's in another country
that's in belarus very friendly history
with the belarusians and moscow you
start to see the activity here and more
in crimea as well then let's go to the
image i just showed you a moment ago as
of three days ago in belarus and crimea
in a significant way putin's got a lot
of options here what's he going to do
what's he going to pull if you look at
his
the possibility if
belarus gives the russian army
the authority to cross its own border
which is a possibility hasn't happened
yet or
putin could come in here from the
northeast there's a main road here that
kind of cuts through on a map that has
the ability
the pavement the construction that would
allow you to take big tanks and big
trucks across ukraine whether he does
that or not we don't know crimea is an
option here down in the south and also
here in the southeast these areas that
putin has declared independent as of 36
hours ago so he's got a lot to do he's
got a lot of options on the table which
one will he pool we do not know but
again midnight in kiev as we speak right
now dana bill thank you i'll see you in
the morning appreciate it we'll take it
around the table now pete just from the
military perspective when you see that
and especially that naval position to
the south there is a possibility that
with the ships there you could see
additional activity even from that side
very much so i appreciate that breakdown
from general hammer
well done uh you're exactly right the
blockade in the black sea is an
important and significant development uh
it cuts off ukraine from from uh
water resources there's also in odessa
an important port there that they could
move towards look at the dots move on
that and it's quite clear exactly what
putin's intentions are we know that
we've talked about it what's happened in
the last 24 hours there hasn't been a
lot but there's a lot that goes into
putting yourself in a position to launch
a full-scale attack on your own terms
which is what vladimir putin has done
and if you look at what the goal of the
americans what joe biden's goal has been
from the beginning it's been deterrence
that's the goal right we want the
deterrence if that has been the goal and
signs point to where we're going right
now that will have been an utter failure
and you contrast that with um
the real politique approach the
unpredictable real political approach
that donald trump took the killing of
suleimani the defeat of isis uh how he
dealt with iran how he dealt with
ukraine the rocket man all of that
strong men around the world understood
we had strength here right now vladimir
putin knows the only thing he's dealing
with is diplomats who think they can
talk their way out of this sanctioned
weakly sanctioned their way out of this
right none of this will deter him this
is all depends on his ambitions the
sanctions jesse are just sort of to i've
been described as timid not enough it's
a little bit here and a little bit there
but i was thinking remember the mother
of all bombs the moab yeah and that was
in the one of the first actions that
president trump took as president and it
surprised everyone and it took everyone
off guard like whoa he's serious why
can't we have the mother of all
sanctions rather than these little
nibbles well living in russia is the
mother of all sections i think they have
a tough life there and they've been
living under sanctions probably their
whole lives especially the last 10 years
or so but you're right this guy's locked
and loaded he's sending blood to the
front lines he's building hospitals he's
already used the cyber he's doing the
information warfare they're they're
they're cocked and you know it's just a
matter of time he's in the driver's seat
and you're right we're all just reacting
to what he's doing and that's not a
great position to be here's my the jesse
waters worst case scenario worst case
scenario
an american
who has not evacuated that country dies
somehow because of combat in that
country
what does joe biden do and if americans
killed by
the russians in ukraine what do we do i
mean god bless them probably nothing
i mean that's a decision that's going to
have huge consequences what happens if
he goes into kiev
like that lightning strike right into
warsaw they don't see that coming goes
right into warsaw
plugs in right there you cut off the
baltics from that western northern
european plane right there and he just
says all right you want to turn your
lights off europe
right because that's what europe's going
to have to do they're going to have to
turn their lights off not buy any energy
from the russians or germany's going to
have to cut a deal with the kremlin and
i don't know what's going to happen
there we going to defend poland we're
going to send people into poland in 2022
i don't know so my best case scenario is
this
he goes into kiev
and stops there and we just load that
country up full of weapons and military
equipment and just bleed him dry with an
insurgency that will be the last
military maneuver that vladimir putin
ever makes that's the best case scenario
what joe biden has to do now he's got to
cut the gas tax he's got to do it
tomorrow he also has to beg opec a
little harder because he already begged
opec to boost production and they
flipped them the bird he's got to start
threatening the saudis with something or
besides please
and
you know other than that he's not going
to do keystone but he's got to lift
these freezes on these leases on the
federal lands and that has to happen
immediately because you can't wait till
it gets to four dollars a calendar can't
wait gotta do it now
uh control room if we have the clapper
sound if you could pull that up so this
is james clapper he was director of
national intelligence under president
obama
in 2014 when president obama was in
office
russia invaded crimea took crimea and
here's what clapper thinks about that
decision now
putin clearly is a lot more emboldened
than he was eight years ago
and we have a lot better intelligence i
wish we as an administration
had uh been more aggressive in in 2014
you think if they should have been more
aggressive in 2014 is there anything
that we have learned about what we
should do in 2022 it's jaw-dropping how
how mild and meek our response was to
the
seizure of crimea almost as soon as it
happened
people were saying well crimea is really
historically part of russia and
sevastopol the big navy bases there uh
you know the the little uh what are they
green men purple men whatever they were
uh you know were were almost expected
and then it just went and something else
happened and we the world's attention
shifted we could have put them there i i
let me start by just disagreeing uh
respectfully with the major on uh bike i
think president biden's team
has accurately forecast everything putin
was going to do
and is now doing and i only hope the
president is wrong
that putin hasn't made the decision to
pull the trigger right now why do i say
that jesse suggests
there could be a move into poland you
know who knows what could happen and
that's true eisenhower said no plan of
action survives first contact uh you
know once war starts you never know
where it's going to go
so i pray that this remains a relatively
localized ukrainian phenomenon i feel
sorry for the ukrainians we'll we'll
fight them in the alleyways and arm
everybody the insurgency will bleed
putin and all the rest of it but what
happens
some of you a ukrainian guy gets a hold
of a nuke or something or is there some
provocation or one russian general
oversteps or you know polish guys do die
or americans do die or some other you
know outrageous act happens as often
happens in all-out war with these tanks
and jets and
artillery and missiles and all the rest
of it
i fear
that unless we can stop this thing
now this could be the beginning of awful
awful consequence this could be
world war iii has to start someplace if
we're going to have that horrible
scenario and all these weapons all these
people occupying the same battle space
uh you know uh who knows and what putin
is thinking i can't imagine what putin
is thinking and what he thinks he's
going to get it and the the president
trump's dni john ratcliff was on earlier
with martha and he said something i was
very interesting katie he said all of us
are being asked these questions of what
will putin do
rather than what should putin do because
we're in a position of just basically
waiting to see what he does rather than
telling him what he should do and then
the line from the white house continues
to be if putin moves we will also move
so they're following from behind leading
behind what putin's actions are going to
be they also keep trying to make this
argument that everything that with the
energy situation that they're doing
everything that they can to mitigate the
cost for americans and the pain of the
pump that's just not true if they wanted
to mitigate the cost they would turn the
keystone pipeline back on they would
hire back all the guys they fired on day
one and they would get 800 000 barrels
of oil a day running through that
pipeline instead of importing 500 000
barrels a day from russia the other
thing i want to bring up here is the the
ukraine nato situation so for years nato
or ukraine has asked to be in nato
they've said we want to pay our fair
share we want to be part of the alliance
we want to have this article 5 situation
against russia just in case they decide
to invade like they are right now
instead of you know ukraine was always
told well you guys have to fix your
corruption issues first joe biden told
them you have to fix your corruption
issues first and instead of actually
helping them fix the corruption issue
the bidens and other politicians in
europe and the united states
participated in it they got rich off of
it and now ukraine civilians there are
going to die
as a result of this chaotic situation
where they were taking advantage of the
lawlessness the corruption in ukraine
not fixing it because if it's a nato
country you can't go in and take
advantage of the corruption right
because there are certain rules about it
so they let ukraine hang out there so
they could all get rich and now they're
screwed they're surrounded really and so
i think people need to remember that you
know they've been asking to be part of
the alliance they've been told nope
while people like president biden have
gotten rich off of it hunter biden got
rich off of it and now they're in a
position where they're in countries like
germany have said they may object why
might that be right germany's getting
its energy from exactly right hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else